It's time to meet another do-gooder or Drew-Gooder.
as we like to call them around here.
According to the National Restaurant Association,
over 100,000 restaurants have closed across the country
since the beginning of the pandemic.
An award-winning food blogger from Phoenix, Arizona
has made it her mission to help restaurants
in her area to avoid a part of, excuse me,
to avoid being part of that statistic.
Diana Brandt, AKA AZ Foodie, made headlines
after she launched a fundraiser to help give back
to struggling restaurants and food vendors.
And she's been using the funds
she raised to leave tips at these restaurants,
sometimes as much as a thousand dollars.
So please welcome Diana to the show.
(audience claps)
I love the way that you are handling wanting to give back.
I find it so unique, so impressionable, so actionable.
You're just dropping giant tips.
Yeah, so I have this platform
called AZ Foodie on Instagram.
And what I started doing, especially when COVID hit,
was just the connections that I've built in the community
and the family and the support,
I saw how they were suffering and how they were struggling.
So many of my friends were scared to lose these businesses
that they had built up over the last seven years.
And I felt like I needed to do something.
And so initially when COVID hits,
I started selling T-shirts, and then we also did a raffle.
And we ended up raising $46,000 for 32 local restaurants.
And that money was used to help keep their employees,
keep the lights on, all that kind of stuff.
And so each week, we're able to go out
and give these tips that are $1,000,
and really just shock and surprise them.
Actually, I believe the money
goes to the entire restaurant, is that correct?
Yes, it goes to the entire restaurant.
If they have a couple of employees there,
that might happen as well.
The other day we gave to a restaurant called Verdura.
And the owner was there and we gave it to her,
and she was just in so much shock and just so happy
because those tips were gonna go to her employees
who aren't making the same amount of tips.
And so they're struggling to pay their bills.
So she was like, hey, this, this money is gonna
help my employee pay their rent this month.
And being so close to it,
it's a very emotional experience to do.
Diana, wow, really, I have so much admiration
and respect for everything you're doing.
When we had heard about what you had done at the restaurant
you just mentioned Verdura,
it's funny because I invited Julia here.
I can't believe you were talking about it.
I was like, (mutters) Julia, hi.
(audience claps)
Hi, how's it going?
Hi Diana, hi everybody.
Thank you so much for having us.
We appreciate you so immensely.
And everything that you're doing resonated with us so much.
And you know, we appreciate it
from the bottom of our hearts.
Thank you, Diana.
And thank you, Drew.
See, surprise Diana, by the way,
nobody mess with Julia, or you're gonna get it.
(audience laughs)
Hello gentlemen, thank you for being with us today.
And Verdura is Spanish for vegetable.
And you are a vegan restaurant, correct?
Yeah, so we're 100% vegan, located in uptown Phoenix.
We've been through the ringer, in terms of COVID,
closed three times now.
And thank you to Diana's generosity
for really showing our staff how important
it means for us to stay in business,
and most importantly, show them our appreciation.
Well, you know, our friends at the plant-based company
Field Roast wanted to join in on the tipping too,
because Diana has inspired all of us, including them.
And we would love to leave a $5,000 tip
at your restaurant.
(audience claps)
Thank you so much.
Well, it's so fitting, 'cause Field Roast
is a plant-based meat and cheese company
who's committed to bringing bold flavor to your plates
at home and restaurants across the country.
And Diana, how you're able to raise these funds
and the way you're giving them,
you're such an inspiration, and you really blew our minds.
So thank you for allowing us in on the party.
And thank you to Field Roast and Diana
and Julia and the gentlemen.
Don't mess with Julia.
And for more information,
on how you can support Diana's initiative.
I say this with like fingers pointing,
'cause I'm so passionate about it.
Visit our website please.
And we would love to eat at your restaurant
as soon as it's safe and possible.
We celebrate you Julia, and Diana and gentlemen, thank you.
Thank you so much for being on the show today.
(audience claps)
(upbeat music)